there's a real issue here after the
Russian interference and you know the
whole influence operation in the 2016
elections and I knew what was going on
and I should do something
you know if not me then you know okay
someone else will go and do but can I
live with myself just sitting on the
sidelines and criticizing what people
are doing you know and kind of you know
worrying about this or am I actually
going to muck in there and you know just
go and do something it's like seeing
your house on fire and you see that you
know okay this is pretty awful and
dangerous but I could go in there and
and do something
to clarify the house on fire meaning uh
the Cyber War that's going on or cyber
attacks the Cyber City well in the 2016
you know when the Russians had
interfered in the election you know I I
mean basically this was a huge National
Security crisis and our politics we'd
gone mad as a result of it and we in
fact we were making the situation worse
and I thought that I could you know kind
of at the time but maybe I could do
something here I could try to clarify I
could you know work with others who I
knew in the government from previous
stints in the government to push back
against this and try to make sure it
didn't happen again and look and I also
didn't have this you know mud you know
kind of crazy ideological view of Russia
either I mean I knew the players I knew
the people I've been studying a long
time and quite calm about it I don't
take it personally it's not kind of an
extension of self
it's you know something I've spent a
long time trying to understand for
myself going back to that very beginning
of my with the Russians trying to blow
us up there must be an explanation there
was it was a very complicated and
complex explanation it wasn't as simple
as how it sounded and also there's a
long tail to 2016 you know Putin's
perceptions the kind of things that he
thought were going on the the you know
the whole way that
what they did was actually fairly
straightforward they've done this before
in the Soviet period during the Cold War
classic influence operation it just did
gone beyond the bounds of anything they
could have anticipated because of social
media and just a Confluence of
circumstances in the United States as
well we were very fragile and vulnerable
and I remember at one point having a
discussion with the Russian ambassador
where you know we were complaining about
the Russian intervention he said are you
telling me that the United States is a
Banana Republic that it's so vulnerable
to these kinds of efforts they actually
looked genuinely mystified although I
mean I'm obviously probably you know
part of a you know kind of political
shtick there but he had a point the
United States had never been that
vulnerable as it suddenly was in 2016.
and in the time that I was in government
and
going back to what you asked about the
whole impeachment and the whole exercise
in uh in Congress
that vulnerability was a stark as it you
know ever could be our domestic politics
were as much a part of the problem as
anything else they were the kindling to
all of the kind of the fires Putin
didn't start any of this other kind of
problems domestically just took
advantage of them and you know basically
added a bit of an accelerant here and
there
yeah the interference I mean that's a
much longer discussion
because uh it's also for me technically
fascinating
um I've been playing with the idea of
just launching like a million Bots but
that are doing just positive stuff and
just being kind yeah I was kind of
wondering if is it possible to do
something on this skill that's positive
because you know a lot of people seem to
be able to use all of this for pretty
negative effect you've got to kind of
hope that you could do this to use the
Sim networks for for positive effects I
think that's actually where a lot of the
war I think uh from the original hackers
to today
what gives people like me and I think a
lot of people that in the hacking
Community pleasure is to do something
difficult break through the systems
and uh do the ethical thing right so do
the um because if there's something
broken about the system you want to
break through all the rules and do
something that you know in your heart is
the right thing to do I mean that's what
Karen Schwartz did with the releasing
journals and Publications that were
behind pay walls to the public
yeah but to me it's fascinating because
I I maybe you can actually educate me
but um
I felt that the Russian interference
in terms of social engineering in terms
of bots all that kind of stuff I feel
like there was more used for political
bickering than to actually understand
the national security problem because uh
I would like to know the actual numbers
involved in the influence I would like
to I mean obviously hopefully people Now
understand that better that are trying
to defend the National Security of this
country but it just it felt like
like for example if I launch one bot
and then and then just contact somebody
at the New York Times saying I launched
this one bot they'll just say uh
MIT
scientists hacks you know and then
but that's exactly what happened it was
you know kind of I think that you know
Putin and some of the people around him
understood because again propaganda
State they spend an awful lot of time
thinking about how you you know
basically put out your own content and
how you get maximum effect through
performance Putin himself is a you know
political pop performance artist I mean
Trump understood exactly the same thing
they were actually operating in parallel
not in collusion but in parallel you
know basically Trump understood how to
get lots of free air time you know how
to get himself a percentage of attention
Putin you know did that through a kind
of I think a less organic kind of way
you know a lot of people working around
it remember that's the old you know
Bolshevik I did prop and you know kind
of then the whole Soviet propaganda
machine and you know Putin kind of
growing up in that kind of environment
and having you know the kind of the
Kremlin press office and all the kind of
people around him got kind of a massive
machine knew how did that worked I mean
they haven't done you know what the
Chinese did in Russia was like you know
blocking everything and having a big
fire while it was kind of putting out
lots of content getting into the you
know the sort of center of attention
Trump's doing the same kind of thing and
the Russians understood that you know if
you put a bit of things out there and
then you call up the New York Times and
people are going to run with it and what
they wanted was the perception that they
had actually sweared the election they
loved it this was the huge mistake of
the Democrats and everything and I kept
trying to push against this no they did
not elect Donald Trump Americans elected
uh Donald Trump and you know the
Electoral College was a key part
Vladimir Putin didn't make that up you
know and basically I also remember
um you know at one point the um Russian
Ambassador you know talking to me about
when we were doing the standard you know
here we are we're lodging our complaint
about the interference you know he
didn't he basically said well we didn't
you know kind of invent Comey and you
know basically the you know the decision
to reopen you know Hillary Clinton's
emails or you know kind of uh Anthony
Weiner and you know kind of his
um you know emails on uh his uh computer
and I was like yeah
he's right I mean you know there were
plenty of things in our own system that
created chaos and tipped the election
not you know kind of what the Russians
did but you know it's obviously easier
to blame the Russians and blame yourself
when you know things are kind of oh oh
those random forces and those random
factors because people couldn't
understand what had happened
in 2016 there was no hanging Chads like
2000 where there was you know kind of a
technical uh problem that actually you
know ended up with the intervention the
Supreme Court There Was You Know pure
and simple the Electoral College at work
and a candidate that nobody expected
including the Republicans in the
primaries you know to end up getting
kind of elected or put forward in a
different 2016 suddenly becoming the
president and they needed a meta
explanation it was much better to say
Vladimir Putin had done it and Vladimir
Putin had been another Kremlin guys were
like oh my God yeah fantastic champagne
pop [ __ ] popping this is great our
Chaos Agent they knew they hadn't done
it but they'd love to take credit for it
and so you know the very fact that other
people couldn't explain these complex
Dynamics to themselves
basically dovetails beautifully with
Vladimir Putin's
uh attempts to be the kind of the
Kremlin Gremlin in the system and he's
you know basically was taking advantage
of that forever more and I wanted you
know to basically try to
work with us to cut through that and the
thing is then you know people lost faith
in the Integrity of the election system
because people were out there you know
suggesting that the Russians had
actually distorted the elections people
written books about that they said you
know that they hacked the system when
you know they were trying to hack our
minds but again we were the fertile soul
for this I mean we know this from
Russian history the role of the
Bolsheviks you know the the whole
1920s and 1930s with Stalin the fellow
Travelers and the you know socialist you
know International I mean the Russians
and the Soviets have been at this for
years about kind of pulling you know
kind of people along and into kind of a
broader friend but it didn't mean
that they were influencing you know
directly the politics of of countries
you know writ large the plenty of
interventions it's just that we were
somehow it was like it was a Confluence
of event a perfect storm We Were Somehow
exquisitely vulnerable because of things
that we had done to ourselves it was
what Americans were doing to themselves
that was the issue you think that's the
bigger threat than large-scale bought
armies
those can be as well obviously they do
have an impact but it's it's how people
process information it's kind of like
the lack of critical thinking I'm just
not on the internet to that extent
either going looking for information I'm
not in social media I'm in social media
but not by myself you know I don't put
myself out there I'm not I haven't got a
Twitter feeder I don't have a Twitter
one yeah but there is
cast and I have all kinds of strange
things it's feeling Health cup which I
kind of like you know occasionally have
people send things to me so many fans
it's hilarious but what I what I what I
try to do is just be really critical I
mean my you know my mum sends me stuff
and I'm like what is this yeah
that's just you know your your own
mother can be as much of an agent of
misinformation as you know kind of
Vladimir Putin oh yeah I mean we're all
you know kind of we all have to really
think about what it is we're reading
there's one thing from my childhood that
was really important I mean I always
think every kid in school should have
this my next door neighbor
um who uh was um he was actually very
active in the in the labor party and he
was you know kind of really interested
in the way that opinion you know shaped
people's political views he was well she
was a native Welsh speaker so you know
he was always trying to explore English
and how you know there was kind of the
reach of you know the English culture
and you know kind of How It's kind of
shaping the way that people thought and
he used to read every single newspaper
you know from all the different
spectrums which is quite easy to do you
know back in the 70s and 80s because
there weren't that many in the UK
context and every Sunday would get all
the different Sunday papers from all the
different kind of ideological Vantage
points and then when I got to be a
teenager he'd invite me to look at them
with him
because it was my godfather and he was
just an incredible guy and he was just
super interesting and you know kind of
culturally you know an outsider always
kind of looking in and he basically runs
through you know what the guardian
looked at the Observer The Daily Mail
the sun you know kind of all of these
you know the telegraph all of these
newspapers and how you could tell you
know their different Vantage points and
of course it's complicated to do that
now I mean in this you know incredibly
extensive media space I look at what it
is that they're saying and then I tried
to you know read around it and then you
know look at what other people are
saying and why they're saying it and who
are they what's their context and that
was kind of busy what I was taught to
look at and and I think everybody should
have that and certainly that's something
that people in politics that are in
charge of directing policy should should
be doing they should be not getting lost
in uh
um
in the sort of the hysteria that can be
created like it does seem that the
American system somehow not the
political system just humans love drama
we're very good like the hunter Biden
laptop Story We there's always like one
two three stories somehow that we just
pick that we're just gonna this is the
stuff we're gonna
fight about
for this election and everyone's got an
opinion on it everybody yeah yeah and
it's the most important like Hillary
Clinton's emails Russians packed the
election yeah we had John podesta's
pasta recipes for a while you know that
we were kind of all obsessing over I
don't know people running out and trying
them out you know something like that
and there's fun uh I mean there's all
the best conspiracy theories about
Giuliani there's I just love it we just
pick a random story sometimes it's
ridiculous and it detracts from what the
larger question should be which is about
the family members of you know senior
officials and mothers they should be
anywhere near any of the issues that
they're you know there's ethics there's
government ethics and things there you
know kind of across the ball but there's
a bigger story in there but that becomes
a distraction it's a look over there you
know the oldest trick in the book you
know kind of idea
because every single member of Congress
and you know government official their
family should be nowhere near anything
they're doing
well that I could push back and disagree
on I I mean well it depends on what the
day if they're making money out of it
you know I'm kind of basically being in
business is what I mean you know kind of
this is a this is
so it's not you know Hunter Biden on his
own it's you know kind of basically the
kids of you know the Trump family the
bitter you name it yeah in general like
that I just think
it's funny like there's a lot of
families that
you know they work very closely together
do business together it's very
successful I get very weird about that
it it just feels like you're not in fact
I don't even like hiring or working with
friends
um initially you make friends with the
people you work with that's right no I
have to I have the same worries as well
because it kind of clouds you know I
would encourage you know my daughter to
do something completely different right
not going to the same field no look it's
different if you're you know in science
or you know mathematics or something
like this and you know maybe you know
kind of you've got a family member
you're kind of building on some of their
theories and ideas you know if Albert
Einstein had a you know kind of an
offspring it was a mathematics and took
you know as fathers thinking you know
further that would be very different but
if it's you know kind of you're in
business and other things and it's just
you know it's the nepotism problem that
you know one has there well it says that
too you know well they do if they're not
people aren't coming and building on the
ideas in a con constructive web right
but even for son daughter of Einstein
You want to think outside the box of the
previous person meaning but I mean it's
just but they shouldn't be sort of told
no sorry you can't go and study math
because you know whatever physics you
know because of but a lot of that you
can't actually make it into law well you
could I suppose but honestly if you do
that kind of thing you should be
transparent there should be just an
honesty about it it gets back to what I
was talking about before we need
diversity of views and diversity of
thinking and you can't have other things
just like being partisan or you know
rooting just for a team you know if
something's going to Cloud your judgment
or it concentrate in the way you think
about things and become you know kind of
a barrier to moving on out and look
that's what we see in the system around
Putin it's kind of kleptocratic and it's
uh you know it's filled with nepotism
all of the kind of like the people who
you kind of see out there in prominent
positions of the sons or Daughters of
including of Putin himself I mean that's
when a system has degenerated and that's
you know kind of and I suppose in a way
this is a symbol of the degeneration of
the system but again it's just a
diversion from you know kind of the
bigger issues and bigger implications of
things that we're discussing